[Musique]
bonjour est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau c'est 8 les invités
voici le sommaire le conservatoire des
arts de montigny fête ses 20 ans
aujourd'hui plus de 500 élèves et 16
professeurs font vivre la structure
pour l'occasion nous ferons un point
avec josé cash a élu à la culture de la
commune
mais on commence ce 7,8 des invités avec
sofia boutayeb trésorière de
l'association b2e impulsion à
l'université versailles saint quentin
avec sa structure à la mis en place un
speed meeting qui se déroule le jeudi 1
jeudi prochain l'objectif est d'aider
des étudiants à mieux choisir leur
orientation
bonjour bonjour alors déjà présenté moi
le b d e impulsion alors le bédat
impulsion c'est une association
étudiante qui a été créée il ya pas si
longtemps que ça en 2014 pour justement
promouvoir la vie associative au sein de
la faculté et donner un élan associative
à ses étudiants lorsqu'ils arrivent à la
faculté de droit
d'accord ok et alors comment est parti
cette idée de speed meeting alors le
speed meeting juridique en fait c'est
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte en
parlant en dix ans entre nous qu'on
n'était pas certain de ce qu'on voulait
faire plus tard on n'était pas certain
de comment y arriver et on se posait
souvent des questions sur finalement
qu'est ce que c'est que le droit et
qu'est ce que font vraiment les
personnes dans leur métier qu'est ce
qu'un notaire qu'est ce que fait
vraiment un notaire tous les jours et
ont du coup de la mairie l'idée de
vouloir faire un speed meeting juridique
ou les étudiants en droit à les
rencontrer en fait chacune des
professions de droit issu de formation
juridique et pouvoir lui poser toutes
les questions possibles et inimaginables
qu'un étudiant en droit se pose dans sa
vie de tous les jours alors donc ça
voudrait dire qu'il y avait un petit
souci au niveau de l'orientation vous
rencontrez pas assez les notaires la
passe et deux stages tout à fait tout à
fait en fait aujourd'hui lorsqu'on lui
effectué unissant juridique il n'y a pas
d'obligation d'effectuer un stage
cette année il ya une tentative en fait
de créer
à cette envie d'aller faire un stage par
une nouvelle matière un nouveau module
qui s'appelle le ppe
donc c'est le module professionnalisant
qui nous pousse en fait soit trouver un
stage ou à effectuer un événement etc
mais sinon il n'y a pas d'obligation de
faire un stage donc du coup les
étudiants qui finissent une licence de
droit se retrouvent généralement perdus
et ne savent pas quoi faire par la suite
n'ont jamais réellement découvert le
côté professionnel des études de droit
c'était une demande des élèves c'était
une demande qu'on a eu autour de nous
moi la première qui avait été assez
perdu sur le choix de mon master ça a
été une jument demande laquelle on a
essayé de répondre de la meilleure des
façons
pourquoi aujourd'hui on est plus pendant
les cours sur des cours de droit ou de
juge quels sont les métiers où il ya un
vrai souci au niveau de l'orientation
en fait nos cours actuellement se
disposer de la façon suivante c'est à
dire que le droit du droit général ont
fait plusieurs droits actuellement elle
trois ont fait du droit des sociétés
vous avez au moins tenu six mois je suis
si moi je pense que non mais on fait
plusieurs droit possible on a dû droit
privé du droit public on nous offre en
fait toutes les possibilités en licence
pour découvrir toutes les matières et en
fait l'étudiant est un peu perdue parce
que on a le côté on va dire théorique
mais on n'a pas le côté pratique et on
ne sait pas en fait
aujourd'hui si on veut devenir notaire
si on veut devenir avocat si on veut
devenir des rh quelles sont les matières
qui vont réellement nous servir et
qu'elle skie qu'est ce qu'on va
appliquer au jour le jour dans notre
métier et c'est là où le speed meeting
intervient alors on va parler de cette
première étape de cet événement qui se
déroule jeudi alors ça se passe comment
alors en fait c'est très simple ça va se
dérouler dans l'ensemble de la faculté
de droit dans le hall de la faculté il
va y avoir différents stands qui vont
être positionnés dans le hall où en fait
les intervenants vont être assis
derrière et les étudiants vont pouvoir
passer de table en table un peu comme un
speed mythe un speed dating où les gens
passent de table en table en posant des
questions en découvrant la personne et
on pouvait lui parler
ça sera de la même façon
henning pas du tout simplement les
événements ne durera pas toute la
journée il est pendant une heure à la mi
mai après six mois de discussions se
prolongent on a quand même des
intervenants qui sont extrêmement ouvert
est extrêmement présent dans au sein de
la faculté et qui j'en suis sûr pourront
répondre même par la suite par mail ou
par par un message voilà ok parlons-en
des intervenants qui les étudiants vont
ils découvrir là bas alors ils vont
découvrir plusieurs personnes notamment
de deux professeurs de la faculté de
droit et de sciences politiques mais qui
ont un métier à côté on aura un notaire
qui sera présent responsable des
ressources humaines
on a également une commissaire des
armées qui ne fera là le l'honneur de
venir au sein de notre faculté
on a un cadre de la fonction publique
qui sera également présent et plusieurs
professions comme ça issu de droit
public de droit privé
malheureusement pas de pénalistes cette
année d'accord mais on a des juristes en
droit social en droit privé
ils ont répondu assez rapidement à cette
demande
étonnamment oui en fait je m'y attendais
pas du tout je pensais avoir plus de mal
à les avoir surtout que ce sont des
personnes qui sont très occupés à côté
qui ont énormément de devoir voilà deux
choses à faire et finalement non ils ont
répondu assez facilement ils se sont
rendus disponibles pour certains en
prenant des jours de congé ou en
éliminant certains de leurs cours pour
pouvoir y est donc je les ai envie qu
ils sont au courant de cette carence
peut-être qu est-ce qui vous disais
quand vous les interpeller
bonne idée ben en fait ce j'en ai
certains d'entre eux qui m'ont dit que
justement eux même en ayant été étudiant
avait été un peu perdu et se retrouver
quelques fois laissé à part henin ne
sachant pas quoi faire par la suite et
donc du coup ils ont voulu aider
justement dans pendant cette initiative
là et pour finir alors c'est quoi la
suite pour votre association parce que
c'est ça c'est aider les autres
étudiants alors vous avez d'autres idées
d'autres événements à nous annoncer
alors ben j'espère par la suite que le
b2 continuera dans cette lancée pour
pouvoir justement aider les étudiants
dans leur vie associative mais aussi
dans leur vie
du coup juridique la lundi dernier on a
reçu monsieur jean louis debré au sein
de la faculté pour une conférence sur le
vertige du conseil constitutionnel
toutabo rayon bleu ça fait donc ancien
ministre sous le président jacques
chirac ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel
ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale grande tyrolienne grande
personne qui nous a honoré de sa
présence justement lundi et qui a
justement pu faire une conférence qui a
été je pense assez bien réussi et
j'espère que par la suite le b2i
impulsion continuera justement faire ce
genre d'événement qui hadrons les
étudiants qui sont en droit ou non
d'ailleurs parce que tous les étudiants
de la faculté enfin de l'université tas
de venir et bien je vous remercie et
donc votre événement si jeudi prochain
dans le hall du bâtiment de droit privé
esprits
versailles saint quentin merci à vous
plus de 500 élèves et 16 professeurs
font vivre le conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux et cette année
cette année est un peu particulière la
structure fête ses 20 ans en deux
décennies des cours ont évolué josé cash
a élu à la culture de la commune nous en
dit un peu plus
il était au micro de mélanie hockey josé
cachant bonjour nous sommes dans la
salle d'exposition du conservateur des
heures de meeting et ce conservatoire à
20 ans c'est important ça il a sur la
commune alors déjà il a 20 ans donc il a
20 ans je crois que c'est significatif
de tout l'attachement que porte la
population à ce conservatoire
quand on vit comme ça pendant une
vingtaine d'années et qu'on évolue et
qu'on suit un peu les mouvements
artistiques aussi c'est important au
niveau des cours qui sont mises en place
etc
je crois que l'important c'est
primordial au niveau de cette commune on
a plus de 500 élèves un taux de
fréquentation qui est extrêmement
important des artistes nombreux qui
viennent professionnels et puis des
expositions amateurs avec les élèves de
notre conservatoire
voilà je crois que tout ce tout
s'explique dans la pérennité de ce
conservatoire avec
l'intention bien bien évidemment de
vivre encore 20 ans supplémentaires
peut-être nous verrons c'est assez rare
conservatoire des arts en général on
pense plutôt au conservatoire de musique
qui conservatoire de danse latine zavan
conservatoire des arts plastiques
on a un conservatoire des arts
plastiques à montigny on est aussi un
conservatoire de musique français des
huiles riches culturellement parlant
voilà on a cette chance de pouvoir
offrir
comme je le disais tout à l'heure un des
activités diverses et variées en matière
d'arts plastiques
cette chance là on là il faut tout faire
bien évidemment pour qu'elle perdure 500
élèves le succès au bayern ne se dément
pas c'est une mission aussi pour la
commune de continuer à faire vivre les
arts oui oui je crois que c'est je crois
que c'est un peu la volonté de toutes
les communes annoncé on sait tous que
finalement la culture en règle générale
les arts mais aussi les différents arts
la musique le chant enfin la danse le
théâtre les arts plastiques etc
c'est quand même la clé pour rassembler
les gens pour le réunir et puis dans le
contexte actuel je pense que c'est
indispensable
il faut il faut aussi attaché à toute
cette richesse qu'on peut avoir son
mobile et pour ses 20 ans la célébration
était est importante
vous vivez à les cours il y à une
exposition d'un but toutes les tous les
visages des acteurs et ya aussi des
expositions anniversaire plus régulière
peut être que d'habitude alors disons
qu'on s'est attaché dans le cadre de ses
vingt ans à faire en sorte d'avoir cinq
expositions de
deux professionnels qui répondent un
petit peu à tous les mouvements
artistiques qu'on peut trouver
et puis qui répondent aussi en quelque
sorte aux cours qui sont qui sont
dispensés dans ce conservatoire
donc on a ces événements là on a une
inauguration au mois de septembre qui
était extrêmement importante
et puis tout au long de l'année on a les
expositions diverses et variées mais des
expositions de nos élèves
voilà avec également dans le cadre de la
la fête de la musique qui se déroulera
le 21 juin
tout un système plastique qui est mise
en place et puis qui va se combiner un
petit peu à cette fête de la musique qui
cette année d'ailleurs se déroulera au
niveau de la médiathèque
en vingt ans il a évolué j'imagine
peut-être pas structurellement parlant
mais en terme de public en termes
d'activités proposées oui bien sûr
justement c'est aussi tout l'intérêt de
pouvoir à la fois fidéliser un public
qu'on a depuis le départ puisque voyez
on avait eu quelques temps avant
l'exposition vous pouvez voir derrière
moi on avait eu une exposition qui
tournait autour du de la mémoire et de
l'hommage qui était portée à ce
conservatoire et plus de 500 portraits
d'élèves anciens et nouveaux qui était
qui étaient exposés donc il faut à la
fois être en mesure de pouvoir maintenir
les activités existantes pour permettre
une certaine catégorie de la population
de pouvoir avancer dans leur démarche
plastique mais aussi s'améliorer et
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
tout en tenant compte un petit peu aussi
de l'évolution des arts dans la société
voyez on s'est lancés cette année dans
la g
ur mais on fait aussi on travaille aussi
beaucoup sur ordinateur sur plein de
choses comme ça donc on essaye en fait
de toucher un peu à tout quoi mais on a
des professeurs qui sont suffisamment
professionnel est doué pour pouvoir
dispenser ses cours là et ce qui fait
peut-être la force aussi c'est
l'amplitude des âges des élèves parce
que ça commence dès 7 ans on va dire
peut-être un peu plus tôt même et ça va
jusqu'à 13 77 ans si on reprend
l'expression de 7 à 77 ans voilà ça
couvre c'est ce que je vous dis c'est à
dire qu'on essaye de couvrir la fois
tous les domaines artistiques mais de
pouvoir aussi répondre à toutes les
catégories d'âge de la population une
vingtaine et vous pensez que ça va durer
vingt ans encore et pas de raison même
40 pourquoi pas pourquoi pas c'est l'as
far de 7,8 des invités merci de nous
avoir suivis prochain numéro
demain bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]